schönen guten morgen sondra wie geht's
dir geht's ja dann ein brötchen mit
avocado hatten wir noch und dann einmal
buttercroissants sagen hat geschissen ja
beliebig zugeben ich habe heute nicht
warum stinkt es da danach scheiße du
bist 48 stunden und das noch keiner
geschissen dem seit gestern haben wir
sogar zusammen zusammengeschossen
[Musik]
du wirst du eigentlich zwei waschbecken
dass seine freundin die einzige obwohl
du gar keine haushalte lukas ich hätte
auch hier hat durch geschaffen um 9 uhr
zu bohren darf nicht mit rein bei
winkler nur zwei leute rein dürfen und
ich habe keine karte sondern ein kumpel
von mir deswegen bat anfang da draußen
das sind man gastfreundschaft
was auch noch was zu erzählen vielleicht
glaubt
dann kommst raus aus nord- oder ganz war
dein fuß hoch nehmen was ist darunter du
schmeißt es in müll das hat auch für die
metro kannst entweder so ein bisschen
grün krams kaufen wie holz oder
bisexuell weihnachtssterne alles andere
hätte nicht gedurft damit auf metro hat
weihnachten auf jeden fall durch
gespielt ich habe keine drehgenehmigung
für in der mit angemeckert heute muss er
warten wohl so viel kohle wir verbringen
wollte das heißt nämlich einfach alleine
ich sage es ist leute mit gefällt immer
weniger warum bis zum auto wir haben hat
die metro chef angerufen
ich darf film also ein heim zweimal
nitro deutschlandchef marken meine
videos
ich finde ich aber auch von entspannen
braucht jeder nochmal so strobl
nach diesen schneemann sieht man mir
wird jetzt auch nicht jeden schritt hier
dokumentiert ist es so wenn du
verschiedene freunde treffen
ja das ist das ist ja ist nicht als
echte die maske die ganze halt schon
aufwand sagst du denn nicht traurig weil
die aus dem film ruft jetzt dürfen wir
ohne zu atmen sehr gut kennt das wenn du
verschiedene freunde treffen fast so
voll deine sprache an
mit dir habe ich mir diesen strombergs
länger miteinander rede ich einfach nur
viel zum vierjährigen ich zeig euch
jetzt mal ich habe manchmal so eine
metro style apps wie wir jetzt hier
durch den laden noch perfekt socken
azra sie liehen jetzt ist es soweit
halt's maul brasilien
er ist so dass er ist so lustig
wollt ihr mich verarschen leute hatten
und fallen jetzt liegen die querung mit
normalen aber das sind da oben gut wir
sind jetzt hier unten aluminum verhalten
dann würden wir in der luft schweben
wenn die da
eine meiner forschung weggedreht
doch nicht weggelegt ja wenn ich jetzt
sagen haben
na klar dass du wieder hier weiß man da
immer durch die raten was dann doch
nicht zum frühstück machen erste mal
dass wir dieses essen also ich zumindest
[Musik]
ich bin kein fleisch
zeigt man ein zweiter junger ihre paten
gibt es rabatt wirtschaft der nette mann
hat sich wurde schon runtergeladen muss
jetzt außer dem was sie ist ganz klar
entwickler und experten noch komisch
sind ethisch fahrstühle wo man steht da
drin
und dann steht man jemand weiter oben
sonst ja
denn richtig motiviert karte
wir sind links das ist doch nix ja weißt
du eigentlich hier mit ihrem auto
rang zurück
dann wollte ich den lustigen job beim
aussteigen machen habt dann allerdings
leider niklas tür gegen so ein feiner
gaumen
du hast du gard volle gegenstoß ich
spüre der feier stand da vor einer woche
noch nicht ich möchte jetzt den job
aussteigen
denn am 1
ja es ist richtig erweise werde ich nie
verstehen alter dann kommst du einer mit
einem daumen auf so eine zahlung
bestürzende waschmaschine produziere
warum gibt man für ein glätteisen mit
diesem bild das macht keinen sinn also
ich ihr ein motorrad für 1400 euro
ja ist schon brutal ist böse unser
ausstieg gehört nicht abgestellt hatte
denn das wenn ihr mit eurer mutter an
der kasse steht im supermarkt und sie
sagt dann bleibt man stehen ich muss
noch mal los so fühle ich mich gerade
ach das ist die handbremse und bei euch
so niklas hat seinen leinwand erfahren
dann schiebt aber auch ja dann also
locker sitzt jetzt hinten im auto
es auch gleich fest wenn ich es hier aus
schnell
ich wollte aus dem fenster schmeißen
eigentlich wir wollten ja eigentlich
schon von einer halben stunde zu hause
sein wir haben ein kleines großes
problem mit der leinwand ja jetzt gerade
die situation sie hat ein ferrari logo
auf ihrem aber drauf doch davon ist das
ist für was machst du da gerade werbung
sondern mir sicher diese mit diesem lied
happy birthday sandra kann das auch ganz
gut singen
[Musik]
das war komplett richtig die lyrics ich
hätte nie gedacht dass ich das mal sage
aber sandra hat einfach gesünderes essen
als ich die hat sich ein salat bestellt
und ichat namibischen reiße ich bin so
ein viertes opfer ich habe heute in der
metro hält die lichterkette gekauft und
ich dass mir ein schönes warmes licht
ist schließlich das seltsam eine
steckdose bin ich ein jahrmarkt oder was
[Musik]